le printemps est arrivé à Ori et avec
lui les espoirs d'une contre-offensive
c'est chacun
on attend tous le moment d'aller libérer
nos territoires l'espoir que bientôt on
va y aller c'est ce qui nous fait garder
le moral
si le plan est tenu secret l'une des
cibles devrait être melithopole la plus
grande ville occupée de la région
Paul et berdianz et en leur coupera
l'accès à la Crimée la partie occupée de
la région de Kerson sera encerclé ils
n'auront plus d'ici nous aurons une
route ouverte vers la Crimée
c'est juste à l'extérieur de Origi il y
a un peu plus d'un an que l'offensive
russe dans la région des aporisa a été
stoppé mais depuis les bombardements
n'ont pas cessé
cette école a été bombardée il y a deux
semaines mais les enfants d'origine ont
été évacués il y a longtemps
dans cet autre école les adultes qui
restent investissent le sous-sol un abri
qui durant la journée offre nourriture
touchée
tous les jours pas seulement aux infos
mais de mes propres oreilles
jusqu'à 17h30 parce qu'à partir du 18h
il y a le couvre-feu alors on monte sur
nos vélos eux ils bombarde et nous on
chaque jour c'est pareil
on voudrait que ça aille plus vite on
est fatigué de tout ça
ce serait bien s'il pouvait bientôt les
repousser ne serait-ce qu'un peu qu'on
puisse respirer
dès le début ses habitants ont choisi de
rester malgré tout
alors aujourd'hui leurs espoirs reposent
sur leur armée